REBOUND, CROWDER.
STAPLE CENTER HAS GOTTEN VERY
QUIET, AS THE PHOENIX SUNS
PULLING AWAY HERE IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER.
EIGHT TO SHOOT FOR CHRIS PAUL.
>> Mark: DEVIN BOOKER IS AT
HALF-COURT TALKING TO THE FANS.
>> Mike: PAUL FOR THREE AND HE
PUTS IT IN.
118-92!
THE SUNS HAVE BLOWN IT OPEN.
37 POINTS FOR PAUL!
>> Mark: BOOKER IS TALKING TO
THE FANS AND UNDERSTANDING WE
HAVE SEEN THIS MOVIE BEFORE.
WE HAVE AN ISSUE ON THE COURT
RIGHT NOW BETWEEN BOTH TEAMS BUT
CHRIS PAUL.
>> Jeff: BEVERLEY AND CHRIS
PAUL.
>> Mike: AFTER KNOCKING DOWN
THAT SHOT, THIS IS NOW LIVE.
BEVERLEY AND PAUL GET IT TO LOOK
LIKE SOME KIND OF PUSHING MATCH
THAT THE PLAYERS ARE GOING TO
THEIR RESPECTIVE BENCHES AFTER
THE TIME-OUT KA CALLED.
-- THAT IS AS UNSPORTSMANLIKE AS
IT GETS. IS WIN.
ALL THAT OTHER STUFF, WE AIN'T
WORRIED ABOUT IT.
JUST WIN THE GAME, OKAY?
BE THERE FOR YOUR BROTHER.
>> Mike: THEY ARE UP BY 26, BUT
PATRICK BEVERLEY, AFTER WALKING
PAST CHRIS PAUL, IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE HE SAYS ANYTHING TO HIM.
BEVERLEY LOSING CONTROL OF HIS
EMOTIONS.
HE IS EJECTED FROM THE GAME AND
CALLED FOR A TECHNICAL FOUL.
BEVERLEY HAD SUCH A GREAT IMPACT
IN THIS SERIES TO HAVE IT MARRED
BY GETTING THROWN OUT OF THE
GAME.
GRANTED, 26-POINT GAME BUT THERE
IS NO PLACE IN THE GAME FOR
THAT.
IT'S BEEN A HARD-FOUGHT SERIES.
THESE TEAMS HAVE BEEN AT EACH
OTHER.
BEVERLEY JUST LOSING CONTROL.
>> Mark: YOU'VE BEEN TALKING